about a third of the United States is
covered in forests in places like
Colorado those forests are in danger
there's fire our wild fires are getting
more frequent and larger a devastating
beetle infestation those trees are all
dead they don't have any branches
anymore they're just standing stick and
global warming there is hope and it's
found in an unlikely place when I tell
people that I work at a forest in
Nebraska they usually laugh and they're
like Nebraska has a forest
Richard Gilbert is a man on a quest
he's a biological scientist who works
here at the Charles Betty nursery in
halsy Nebraska it's the oldest federal
tree nursery in the US the nurseries
main mission is to help preserve and
repopulate national forests in the Rocky
Mountain region without Bethy they're
not going to be able to have the supply
of tree that they need for reforestation
but they have a castra feed we can be
there to help them
what I love most about my job is really
the change in season the change in work
that I do I get to work in the seed bank
I get to work him a container part of
this I get to work in the field and I
get to actually get my hands dirty I
don't just sit in an office and in push
paper which is amazing he really cares
and he's always trying to make it better
we turned the greenhouses on you got
little seedlings germinating to me this
spring so my spring starts really early
and it's extremely rewarding he's very
proud of his work he's very proud of his
trees I love growing plants and helping
them grow I don't ever want to leave
that that contact with the plant when
they need him we grow them and we get
them produced in less than a year
all of the trees are produced in the
greenhouses and then they are brought in
here on tables this wire is okay cause
it's above halfway and we had a central
leader we can act 110 to 120 thousand
trees per belt per day we're packing
container trees for the San Juan
National Forest they don't get their
moisture in the spring a lot of times
they get their summer monsoon season
that's when they want their seeding
delivered which it remembers all of this
information you must the feedback and
wants to know how they did at our best
we might get 70% 80% survival without
Bethy they're not going to be able to
have the supply of tree that they need
for reforestation
[Music]
you
plants are just amazing and there are so
many of them out there and I will never
know how to grow every single one if
it's a very very interesting plant I'll
try to produce it and grow it at the
house and you guys drive by my house
over there you'll understand you'll see
all the different plants that I have
over there
[Music]